in the heart of Beijing these crowds are
waiting to get into the Forbidden City
once the home of Chinese Emperors know a
popular spot for family visits
it's the first time that I have visited
the Forbidden City with my children I
want them to have a good experience and
enjoy the atmosphere of Beijing so they
can learn more about ancient Chinese
culture I just take my children out for
fun life was not easy for the past three
years but people are still united we
want to come here and see the prosperity
of the country unlike the New Year
holiday which is traditionally spent
with family the five-day Mayday holiday
is mostly for leisure travel Beijing is
the most popular destination for
travelers this week booking sites Show
tickets for popular destinations like
the Forbidden City and the Great Wall
are already sold out
transport hubs are seeing huge crowds
authorities expect more than 16 million
trips to be made across China's rail
network on the first day of the holiday
the May Day holiday is a very important
time for stimulating consumption
including shopping food and beverage
tourism Leisure entertainment and it
will boost all of these areas a lot
people have been waiting for this long
holiday it's one of the best times of
the year to go out for fun
the China tourism Research Institute
says more than 240 million people will
travel over the holiday but they say it
may take some time for profits to catch
up to pre-pandemic levels as Trends
indicate people are traveling more but
spending less
still a boost in visitor numbers is
welcome news for small business owners
there were no people on the street
during the pandemic so what could I do
everyone was under lockdown and I had to
stay home too our business I all rely on
the tourists since more people coming to
Beijing my business will be better he
hopes the hardest point in his working
life is behind him now he says he wants
to focus on The Simple Pleasures sunny
weather good business and the smiles of
his customers
Jessica Washington Al Jazeera Beijing